we found this video over the weekend uh
this is director Alan Hughes he did a
great Tupac Shakura documentary he did
Broken City with Mark Wahlberg Menace to
Society he was asked about wokeness and
what it's doing to society and I thought
this was pretty great I brought up
George Clooney right being the
traditional Hollywood liberal right yeah
right I'm biracial so let's start with
that I I can I can see both sets because
I I can't imagine what he's thinking
right now he's probably at home like
just shook and and doesn't know what to
say or do for fear of being called
something right I'm talking about a
liberal yeah because woke us has got so
bad
um that people are
digging up [ __ ] you said in the 70s
I'm thinking of [ __ ] you said in the 90s
not even the 70s right good the culture
always changes the the Lexicon changes
you got to start judging people on [ __ ]
like that
then we gotta tear down all the statues
we gotta take MLK now yeah we got to
take JFK down
so why I wanted to show this was here
you've got a documentarian guys working
with Tupac like this is not a guy who
would be thought of he's certainly not a
conservative I don't think by any
stretch but the point is he's saying hey
Libs it's even coming for you it's even
coming for you now yes were there a
whole bunch of us saying this a long
time ago yeah but but there's something
interesting going on there